c'est un voleur qui est en train
d'après-midi non c'est quoi maison un
voleur ah d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il leur demande de leur donner de
l'argent les bijoux tous les biens
qu'ils veulent le mari le l'homme se met
à sangloter non non soyez gentils prenez
tout ce que vous voulez mais laissez la
partie laissez la partir soyez je vous
donne même ma carte bleue avec le code
si vous voulez mais laissez la partie
allez donc tu vas droit loin de ta femme
toi mais non non elle arrive d'une
minute à l'autre
bravo
remplaçant pour l'emplace une journée
puis le lendemain il arrive il lui
demande alors qu'on s'est passé très
bien enfin j'ai pas eu beaucoup de
clients si j'ai un truc qui avait mal à
la tête alors j'ai donné les cacher pour
et puis après j'ai un outil qui est
arrivé il avait lui il avait mal au
ventre je le détacher puis après
j'aimerais bien compris là je commence à
te dire qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il y a
une femme qui est rentrée très belle
très très belle très elle s'est
déshabillée complètement nue sur le
complètement nu bah alors qu'est-ce que
tu as fait avec qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire qu'est-ce que tu as vu qu'est-ce
que tu lui as dit bah je lui dis
qu'est-ce qui vous arrive madame ben
j'ai pas vu un homme depuis 6 semaines
et alors tu as fait quoi tu as fait quoi
j'ai mis des gouttes dans les yeux
[Applaudissements]
pour la première fois à Paris alors il
se fait la tournée de tous les monuments
la Tour Eiffel il va finir par la Tour
Eiffel il fait tous les autres à remplis
à la Tour Eiffel et monte au dernier
étage pour voir une dernière vue de tout
Paris il est tout seul ah non il y a un
monsieur qui est dans le coin là il est
bizarre il est comme ça il fait 53 53 53
53 il le regardait ta gueule il a pas
l'air bien celui-là il s'approche lui
ose pas trop quand même 53 53 53 il se
rapproche quand même monsieur ça va
oui il le prend il le jette de la Tour
Eiffel et reprend 54-55
[Applaudissements]